Hi everybody.
I just want to get right to it.
Let me please introduce our wonderful guest today.
We have a day Patel,
the star of the film,
and Luke,
Luke Davies,
the screenwriter,
and then a special treat.
We have the real life sorrow Brierley in house.
Please help.
So welcome to Google.
Yes.
Hello.
Thanks.
How was your lunch?
It was the first question us.
Yeah.
Uh,
great.
Well,
uh,
some of the folks in the audience haven't had a chance to see the film yet,
so I thought I could start with a question for you,
Luke.
Uh,
maybe you could tell us about the film as well as,
tell us what attracted you to this particular story.
Very simply,
it's a true story about a five year old boy.
Uh,
this is him now as an adult.
And this is the guy who plays him as an adult,
uh,
who under very traumatic and calamitous circumstances.
One day gets lost on a train and winds up,
um,
2000 kilometers away in Calcutta.
Uh,
after many scrapes,
he winds up in an orphanage.
He gets adopted by an Australian couple.
He grows up in Australia.
He loses his Hindi,
Hindi and 25 years later he learns off the existence of Google earth and he has
about five memories in his head,
visual memories from when he was five years old of his village.
And he starts following the railway lines out of that train station where he
arrived at Cal Carter.
There's massive train station.
Uh,
and then more and more obsessively following those railway lines looking for
matches to these visual clues.
And what attracted me to it was just that it's a magnificently pure and simple
fable about,
um,
reunification with the lost mother and maternal love and hope and persistence
and love.
It was,
I just wanted to write this screenplay that was very simple and very powerful.
Yeah,
it was a lot of universal themes in the film.
Great a day.
My next question is for you,
uh,
I had the honor of being at the tail tiff premiere where this film got a
standing ovation and I think it was the runner up for the audience award as soon
as resonating with audiences.
And I was just curious,
why do you think that is?
What do you think about the film is causing people to really have this very
visceral reaction to it?
Um,
I really think it's an anthem of a unity in humanity really.
you know,
it's so triumphant.
It's core.
It's a story about mothers and sons and,
uh,
you know,
I think that those themes are so universal,
and um,
you know,
that's what you want to do when you go into this dark room.
You want to be transported and inspired and,
and you know,
the fact that,
you know,
we're breathing a second life into what is essentially a true story,
which this young man here so bravely transversed is,
it makes it even more inspiring.
Great.
Thanks.
Sorry.
Um,
so those game we all played growing up,
who would play you in a film and so no to that.
Did they pull it off?
Look,
did an amazing
job.
Yeah,
he has.
He has pulled it off.
That wasn't my real question.
Uh,
now my real question is,
um,
you know,
uh,
you saw the film and,
you know,
I'm curious about your reaction to seeing it,
but more how did it change your understanding of your own story?
Having seen a dramatize in a film,
did it change how you saw your own journey and your own discovery of,
uh,
birth parents?
It didn't really,
because,
um,
I've lived,
you know,
and I've told my story so many times to my parents and myself,
um,
sort of,
you know,
internally and,
but seeing it for the first time,
I thought I'd be quite desensitized from it because I've lived it.
And,
uh,
but,
but it wasn't not that at all.
It was,
um,
I was just so sort of intuit,
clinching onto,
you know,
my knees and,
um,
and you know,
there was such a pivotal times,
um,
we're crescendo the points where,
you know,
I had tears in,
in myself as well.
So,
um,
you know,
the movie was just so true,
no to my story,
which is great.
And,
um,
and yeah,
it's just,
um,
and just looking at it,
you know,
the way they've done everything was just amazing.
And,
um,
and it,
you know,
there's,
there's auditorially talking about it,
which I had been for such a long time in being written in the book as well,
but seeing it out,
um,
and played out with the day of and in the other states whose,
it was just another sort of level I guess,
um,
which not only myself,
but my family got to see it to my adoptive family.
And,
um,
and also,
you know,
people in the world to,
what was it like to see it with your adoptive family?
I'll look.
It
will because I used to tell him so many times,
this is the events in the stages and phases that I went through,
um,
in India and now they actually can see what it really is visually.
And that visual,
um,
since got heightened,
uh,
from the auditorium and,
um,
and they just broke down.
You know,
dad just said,
we didn't really know,
you know,
even though you told us and what you went through.
But seeing it was just another climax in your senses.
And we all sort of,
um,
after seeing the movie just sort of cuddled each other and,
and yeah,
for about 30 minutes.
And,
um,
it was just such a pivotal moment there of letting them actually see something
that they hadn't sort of been longing for such a long time.
Did Nicole Kidman pull it off for your mom?
She did.
Amazing job.
She's like that,
that uh,
there's a,
there's a person,
there's a specific scene where she tells us,
tells me it was you.
Um,
so,
um,
about,
you know,
being,
um,
you know,
not having children where she states that,
they could actually have children,
but,
um,
mom and dad collectively decided not to because they wanted to help someone that
was more in need than sort of having children themselves.
Great.
Thanks Dave.
The next question for you.
So as product manager of Google Earth,
I have to have one question about it.
Uh,
and it's generally when you see technology and films computer,
is there generally a foil or a prop where I think what's nice about this film,
what's especially touching at me as you brought this product to life and I think
it's where you're acting and you're reacting to the product.
And I was just curious what was the process to really kind of bring this to life
and have it.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Well,
um,
I've said this before,
but I spent a lot of my career staring in front of all these scenes,
these screens,
you know,
pretending to gather all this information and run to a character that's more
important than myself.
And you know,
I'm playing a plethora of,
um,
you know,
tech centric guys.
But you know,
the interesting thing about this is a,
you know what,
I'm sitting in front of this laptop and it's an entirely emotional experience.
That relationship with technology that Saroo has,
you know,
he's looking at this screen,
he's looking at those blurry pixels,
which is what it was back in the day.
You know,
the refresh rates and the W it wasn't as developed as it is now and he's drawing
so much history,
so much pain,
so much,
um,
memory from these,
these pixels.
So it was kind of some of the hardest stuff I've ever had to do,
you know,
as a performer and a is really validating,
to finally be able to sit in front of a screen and uh,
I feel like you're doing something of a real gravitas.
Yeah,
I heard you got Google earth training lessons.
I did.
It was in the schedule,
I think it was twice a week.
That's just sit down and you,
you helped with the program,
you gave us the right a little bit.
Yeah.
Just made us period.
Perfect.
Yeah,
just one small detail that I think is really why I love the fill it's so
authentic is um,
you know,
Google Earth right now we've launched version seven,
but when they were in the film,
they were using four and five.
Uh,
and we had to do some archeology to find those old versions and make sure they
worked on laptops.
And if you watch the film very carefully,
the first time he uses it,
it's earth for the second time he uses it.
Or later in the film it's earth pro five,
which is just to say these filmmakers paid a lot of attention to detail and all.
And it's very authentic that way.
Nothing's nothing that they did with the product or you know,
with really anything in the film I think took unnecessary liberties.
And that's why part of the reason I think it's so powerful is that authenticity.
Um,
Luke,
so we talked a little bit about this,
uh,
about,
these universal themes of home mothers and sons finding your own identity and
what other pieces of art books,
movies,
um,
art inspired you or did you draw from to kind of tell this universal story?
You called it a fable earlier.
Are there other
very,
very specifically the,
um,
the first act of the film where we're,
where it's the five year old actor,
Sunny Parr who plays Saru as the five year old who gets lost.
Um,
my model for that first hour of the film really was,
um,
is Wally,
is the,
is the robot wandering around the post apocalyptic kind of environment.
Um,
and so I wanted to kind of create something of the texture of the feeling of the
first act of Wally,
which I find a really emotional first hour.
That film to me changes direction slightly.
When it gets up into space,
it's suddenly a bit of a different tonal world.
So,
uh,
that was my big influence for the first part of the film.
The rest of it was just trying to find a way of telling this extremely
emotionally heart breaking and heart wrenching story.
Um,
and to make,
my aim was basically to see if I'm sitting in the audit in a theater and I can
hear people crying around me,
I feel great
there.
And this is a multiple Kleenex kind of film.
Absolutely.
The first time we screened it here for Googlers,
there's a lot of ugly crying in front of coworkers.
Uh,
so sorry.
Um,
what is the message that you want people to take away from this film when they
see it?
What do you hope is communicated by it?
And they take away from seeing your story traumatized?
Well,
um,
when you read the book and I guess,
you know,
you'd be sort of the same.
It's watching the movie as well that I think,
you know,
at the end of the day it's a powerful movie,
uh,
to individuals.
Uh,
no matter who you are really.
And what sort of state of frame of mind you,
um,
you be at the end of it.
But I'm really,
at the end of the day it'd be sort of a empowerment,
um,
of understanding,
in,
you know,
knowing that there is actually a way,
if you were sort of ever to be in a position that I was in,
um,
perhaps these are this kinds of things that you could use from,
you know,
extracting,
extrapolating from your memories,
um,
how to sort of find your hill way home with,
uh,
you know,
it's from people from the war or,
um,
people from different countries.
Um,
I really think,
you know,
that's sort of the,
the main thing out there as well.
As you know,
there's other things as well as in like,
you know,
love and,
um,
and family and you know,
unification.
Um,
and you can just sort of talk about it and sort of so many different ways from
political to social,
um,
to,
uh,
sort of,
um,
hallway but other things.
But,
um,
I think that's the main one really,
that there must be other people out there that have been in the same situation
but just haven't been able to sort of,
you know,
understand what their feelings and,
their dreams are telling them.
And this is the,
this is a story that,
you know,
when you've been dreaming for something that,
it means that you've been longing for it and he must suppress it,
diffuse it somehow and,
and listen to it.
And that's what I did.
I,
I headed for such a long time,
these memories.
And when I came to,
you know,
when I was 22 and 28,
um,
I,
I didn't know what to do,
but I sort of use,
you know,
the feelings and the dreams and all that.
And,
um,
and,
you know,
went out and did what I did because otherwise if you don't,
it's just going to stick with you for such a long time.
And,
um,
and before you know it,
you're maybe too old,
um,
to do anything about it,
but you know,
you certainly got to listen to your heart and your dreams.
They mean something.
Do you remember the exact moment that you learned about Google Earth?
Um,
when I was,
uh,
when I was at school at the Canberra University there,
that's,
that's when I,
um,
sort of got in touch with it because Sam was talking about it.
I was a 2005,
late 2004,
2000 seats.
Swine,
Google first launch.
Yeah.
So that's,
you know,
for me,
Google Earth was embryonic.
Um,
when I was in my early twenties,
when I looked at the map in my bedroom,
I was like,
you know,
I can't find my home town using the map because I can't find Cardwell.
Uh,
well I didn't know it back then.
I can't find boring poor.
Um,
but the visual memories that I have a thought to myself back then in my early
twenties,
that they must be or will be a program later in the future,
they'll come out that I could use those memories and it evidentially has
happened.
Google earth.
That's great.
Um,
couple more questions but then I'm going to turn it over to audience questions.
If you guys want to start to think of questions and uh,
start to line up,
but I think they'll set up the mic in the back.
Um,
so a day,
my next question is for you,
I was looking at your imdv page and looking at some of the films that you've
made and be gentle
please.
Okay.
We won't talk about this early films,
but uh,
you know,
there,
there's an interesting theme that happens in a few of your films.
Slumdog of the man who knew infinity and of course lion,
it's a character leaves their home to discover their destiny and then comes
back.
Maybe that's how I'm looking at it.
And you actually have an interesting sort of ancestry where your ancestors are
from India.
Your parents grew up in Nairobi and then you grew up in London and now reside in
the states.
So with all of these things,
what does home mean to you now?
You don't have characters that have discovered it in different ways in your own
life.
I was home redefined,
redefined.
Uh,
God,
that's interesting.
I do,
I do gravitate towards the idea of a fish out of water,
you know,
I can relate to that.
You know,
you know,
going to school I was never really popular or anything like that,
so I always felt like a bit of an outsider looking in at times.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I left home when I was 16,
you know,
and discovered India shooting this film,
some dog for the first time.
And it was a completely eye opening experience.
It was part of my heritage that I had shunned growing up for a long time so I
could fit in,
be normal,
be be like everyone else.
And when I went there and witnessed this city with this amazing Bombay,
Mumbai,
this amazing filmmaker Denny Ball,
you know,
you're seeing things,
going into the slums and,
you know,
just dusting incredible,
incredible things.
It kind of,
um,
open up my mind to a higher level of consciousness,
I guess.
And,
uh,
you know,
I've gone back since and done five films,
but you know,
home to me,
I have a fascination with trees.
This sounds very hippy,
so just stick with me here.
But I,
uh,
whenever I go to a hotel or something,
I'll draw a little tree.
It looks like a piece of Broccoli,
but as the best like,
and then I write,
grow next to it and I sign it and leave it on.
And the idea of it is,
uh,
you know,
home is the roots to me.
And the roots are so important because if the,
you know,
that's where the tree gets us nourishment.
It's strength.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's grounding.
And from there with good roots and a knowledge of home and a connection to it,
you can grow on,
you know,
grow into this mighty tree bearing fruits.
And,
and I know it sounds crazy,
but you know,
that's my idea of it.
And I've,
I feel my parents,
everybody,
everybody who works in Google Earth as a hippie.
So you're in good company.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
It was a beautiful,
I asked a hard question.
Um,
so last question is actually for all of you and it comes from our followers on
social media.
So we posted a question,
what would you like to ask you guys?
And the question is,
what was the most exciting or inspiring scene for each of you in the film?
And if other folks want to start lining up for questions,
please feel free.
Well,
you wrote it.
It's based on you.
So,
but yeah,
I love the scene where,
uh,
where Dev comes to see sue,
his mother played by Nicole Kidman and,
um,
and he finds out that they chose not to have kids,
that she could have had kids,
but they chose to help kids who are already alive.
I really liked that scene a lot.
I agree there too.
Yeah,
that was pretty special.
I had a front yeah.
Row seat to Nicole Kidman,
just pouring her soul out and uh,
you know,
she really performed from the gut and that,
but,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
I mean,
all of it for me was completely profound.
You know,
as a,
I grew up in the process filming the movie,
you know,
and,
and golf is one of those directors that allows you to really be open and
exposed.
But,
uh,
am I allowed to talk about the end?
Is that even,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know,
but uh,
there,
there's so many,
but um,
you know,
one that the end,
you should watch,
but it's very,
they've seen it.
They've seen enough or enough of them.
I've seen it,
there are enough of them seen it.
But that scene,
uh,
as,
as real as it gets,
you know,
I,
that was the first thing I shot in the film.
So I flew out to,
to,
to India and uh,
Garth was like,
you know,
as a little sperm you are swimming up to this moment,
so don't mess it up.
I was like,
okay,
no pressure then.
Um,
but you know,
it,
it's terrifying cause you know,
so much rides on this moment of unity.
And uh,
we get there and we start filming me and Priyanka who plays the Indian mother,
she's an incredible actress and there's not much to do in the kind of location
that we were filming it.
So every night we would all be having dinners and things and he's like,
you can't see it now for a week before we shoot this.
And the next time I saw her was in the scene.
So this,
this man was like,
wait a second.
And he goes away,
comes back,
and I started following him through these alleyways and I come out to this
opening and then at the end of the,
you know,
far in the distance,
I can see these three figures and they start approaching me and we're getting
closer.
And I started to recognize it to Priyanka and they've done this incredible
makeup on her face to HR and,
uh,
you know,
all these,
there was no planted extras.
You know,
all those people in the village where there were real villages,
they didn't understand what I was saying.
Um,
but they could feed off that energy,
the truth.
And,
um,
by the end of it,
I felt like I was in Avatar because we're embracing,
we're crying.
It's a moment of complete joy and sadness also.
And,
um,
you know,
that all these hands to start reaching out and feeling my face and touching me,
and you look around and they're crying with you and laughing with you.
And,
uh,
it was,
yeah,
that was a really special moment.
Yeah.
Well,
he has a great stop.
Oh,
go ahead.
Well,
I also,
I would love to speak because we're here.
I love in terms of the technology of the film.
I love that moment right near the end where you're pretty much giving up where
you zoom out fully up through India and,
and the whole of the planet is just like hovering there in space at this final
moment before you start to zoom back in.
That moment to me is like,
ah,
hairs on the back of my neck.
Really sound designer that where they make you feel hollow.
Right.
That's
amazing.
That's amazing.
All right,
great.
Well we have some audience questions.
Uh,
so we'll start with the first one please.
I want to thank you for the film.
I saw it a couple of days ago and I don't remember the last time I cried at a
film.
My question is,
is what happened to your mother in India?
What,
what's up with her now?
Oh,
um,
she's good.
She's healthy.
So he's my brothers and sisters.
Um,
and uh,
and I bought her house,
um,
because before she was a reading a house and so,
mmm.
And the house was,
you know,
there has that she's been living in,
she didn't want to sort of move away to anywhere else,
uh,
because her friends were,
you know,
within that sort of vicinity of the house.
Um,
so she,
she just wanted that house and I sort of put some money in every month just to
sort of help her out and she doesn't have to really work anymore.
Um,
but,
but she's good log sheets,
probably fitter than me.
Really.
Um,
amazing woman.
So strong mentally and physically and um,
yeah,
I think I've got good traits,
no wrinkles,
million dollar ones.
Um,
and um,
and yeah,
so I'm really happy.
She's about 63,
64 I use of age.
Um,
and um,
but she's just doing really look great and we talk just about every month
through a translator.
So,
and I've seen her about 14 times.
She's still in Canada?
Yes.
Yeah.
So she's still there in the same house.
Um,
so,
um,
I'm really fortunate actually,
that,
um,
she's got good health,
so that's great.
Great.
Hey guys,
I'm John.
I'm on the Google Earth Hour.
Each team.
I know I wanted to ask,
if you could go back in time to 2005 when you first discovered Google earth,
if there was one feature you could add,
still would have made your journey's yeah,
off the record.
I tried to crack it and cannot penetrate into Google.
Um,
yeah,
I've got a hacking,
but it was,
it wasn't very good.
Um,
um,
that's okay.
We know all about it.
Shield did didn't work.
Um,
I don't,
I'm not too sure really.
I think everything just happened the way it mean to happen.
My destiny was meant to happen that way.
But um,
but I think if the clarity of,
um,
you know,
Google Earth back then was a lot better then the whole search would have been,
a lot easier as well as the speed,
the refresh rates and so on.
But funny thing about it is that,
you know,
that version of Google Earth,
when I saw my hometown,
I would have been the only person in this world that knew where those landmarks,
where and what and what they were as well.
And for a normal person,
they were looking at,
you know,
something that I was looking at on Google,
assuming Dan back then,
um,
they would have gone,
what is that?
It just looks like a bush.
But no to me,
I could tell them right down to the grassroots what it is and that's how sort
of,
you know,
have you been mind memories were so guess,
if it was a little bit more the clarity,
the resolution would have been better.
It helped.
Okay,
great.
It sounds like what I was meant to be happened.
Well that's right.
You know,
um,
the children that came out of that,
the Isa,
which is the Indian Society of [inaudible] and adoption,
um,
I just think we're all Destiny's child and we carve out and Mike what the future
is for ourselves.
So things were meant to be the way the word [inaudible].
That's,
that's how it was meant to be then.
Thanks.
Thank you guys so much for being here with us today.
Um,
through,
I wanted to ask you,
there's no way to collapse decades of your rich life into a buck or into a
movie.
So I was wondering if there's any events or relationships or nuances of your
life that maybe didn't make it into the public eye that you might be able to
share with us?
Well,
it's,
it's a massive story.
Um,
I think there's,
you know,
there's,
there's quite a few sort of events,
um,
and stages or phases of the,
the whole journey,
um,
raw from inception that could have been in there,
but,
um,
or great,
you know,
or great raw data.
Um,
but,
um,
I think these sort of the main,
you know,
one's,
um,
you guys sort of peak pretty well.
Um,
especially Luke Day.
He was a script writer.
Um,
I think,
uh,
one of them would have been the drowning in the river in the Hughley river.
Um,
can I tell a little bit about that story for people who don't know?
Oh,
okay.
So actually they did put it in there,
but it was in an early draft of the script and then,
so I had to lose it.
Yep.
And the draining of the Hughley River,
I'll tell you about it and what it is.
I didn't know how to swim,
but I love the border and the Hughley river has a tidal system.
And I didn't understand that I was only a kid.
And,
um,
and I was jumping off a ledge onto a,
sorry,
I step onto another step.
And I was having so much fun that I didn't realize that I was going step by step
by step,
even by the,
to the point where there was no step at the end of that stamp brought down the
bottom because the Todd had sorta gone down.
And um,
and I jumped in and,
um,
in the tide and there was no bottom and I didn't know how to swim.
The rips got me and I'm just,
and I'm just like going down and then up,
down,
up for a couple of times.
And then the last time us just took the tiniest bit of breath and I was just
going down to the obese and I thought,
you know,
that's the end of me.
And I saw the light,
the sun sort of dim more and more and more.
And I'll put my hand up.
And the only thing that Ahca think of at that point of time was my mother and my
sister.
And I was just thought to myself,
hope they're okay even though I'm about to sort of go.
And all of sudden out of nowhere,
this hand,
this angel,
this hand just came in,
grabbed me out.
And um,
and yeah,
it was,
that was,
that was the most amazing beat.
Such a powerful,
you know,
point of time.
Which hand was it?
Um,
it was,
um,
it was just a guy,
one of the store workers that actually somehow had noticed this kid,
you know,
his hands going up and down,
um,
bobbing up and down.
Um,
and,
um,
if it was any longer than I would've been gone.
Great scene.
One of the reasons that had to go,
it was just because it would've been a super expensive day with safety officer's
underwater cameras,
uh,
health and safety issues that were extremely problematic,
problematic in that river in terms of insurance.
It would have been a gnarly day shooting and it would have cost a lot of money.
So,
but there were other reasons too.
Why in the end it went,
it's a,
it's a beautiful moment.
I don't think I could have cried one more time in the film,
but that would have been like,
you could almost think that,
Ooh,
from the audience point of view,
um,
oh,
he's going,
she know how the story ends there.
But um,
it's amazing.
You know what,
what's out there really.
Um,
uh,
I'm very fortunate actually.
Very survivorman please.
Hi,
I'm this one's for Luke.
What was the process like turning the book into a script?
Like how do you choose the important moments?
Because there's a lot of material,
right?
For me,
I,
I just always tried to keep in mind that this story was about this very singular
emotional journey towards wholeness.
All the rest of it was just,
uh,
frills and trappings,
including the technology.
The technology had to only serve us,
uh,
so rosy emotional story.
Um,
technically the process was I had a previous relationship with the producers.
They said,
have you heard this story about this Indian cuter got lost?
And that was the week that the story had been floating around because the book
had just come out and I had heard the story.
Uh,
I kind of auditioned for the job.
I wrote a story,
I read the book quickly.
I wrote a structure of how I would approach the film.
The main big thing was that from the very beginning,
I said to them,
this story is so powerful and so amazing.
Do you mind if I try to write the first draft of the screenplay?
We don't do the typical thing and begin with your star adult actors and
establish them and their world and then something happens and then you look back
and tell the story and come back to where you were.
Let's try and begin at the beginning with a five year old actor at the moment he
steps on the training,
gets lost.
Uh,
and they,
they were really supportive of that.
So it always had a very linear structure.
Um,
the process was just trying to find the biggest emotional storylines that made,
gave the story a really good beginning,
middle,
and end.
And that when you reach the end,
you feel a sort of,
I would call it a kind of triumphant,
exhilarating sadness if the film works.
It's both sad and extremely hopeful and triumphant.
Thank you so much for joining us.
My name is Celine.
I'm on the Google Earth outreach team.
Um,
I'm particularly interested in,
in your perspectives on storytelling.
Storytelling has been for thousands of years away to raise awareness and bring
community together and through any,
and I think the,
the,
the methods have changed over time and technology is certainly at a,
at an interesting place from my perspective now of of enabling maybe the same,
maybe different types of stories.
Can you talk a little bit about how you see storytelling changing or changed
over time and maybe going forward from the perspective of how technology can
help or plays,
plays a role there?
Well,
I think that the technology changes constantly and that's,
that's just something to be embraced.
But the stories I think remain extra.
The great stories remain really a prime primitive,
not primitive,
but primal and elementary and elemental,
that's the word.
Um,
and this one for me,
I just imagined that the story of reunification with the last mother,
this basically has to be one of the oldest stories in the history,
in the emotional history of human civilization.
It's got to be as old as it can possibly get from the origins of our
civilization.
Reunification with the lost a mother.
There was no kind of more powerful force.
I think then maternal love and the,
and a,
a story about the loss and deprivation of maternal love is really,
um,
it's full of peril and that's hopefully what drives this film.
Yes.
And um,
and also Google earth and,
um,
and how it's being used.
That's technology which,
um,
which,
which is the other part of the story too is that,
you know,
when I,
when I'm doing my search,
how am I going to use these memories in my head,
uh,
and by using technology,
which is out there and no one's really thinking about it.
Um,
but I am,
it's like,
you know,
it's this application,
um,
out there in a lot of people you know,
that are here,
just use it to look at their houses.
I've been,
I did myself,
um,
rooftop,
but,
um,
but it's,
it's just that,
um,
that idea that's just crystallized in your head as in like this application
could be utilized from our own personal benefits and,
um,
and you know,
when I did use that idea and thank God,
you know,
Google Earth did come when it did.
Um,
otherwise if it wasn't there for me then I don't think we'd be here sort of
talking.
That's true.
Right.
Dave,
actually,
maybe you could take a crack at that question where storytelling fits into the
world we live in today and what purpose it serves and society.
I mean,
I think it's the highest form of escapism,
you know,
there is,
um,
I aye.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
that's something that really I connected to as a young child was going in and
watching films.
It's shaped the way I think,
my ideals,
everything about the way I see the world.
So,
um,
for me,
you know,
especially when you go to India and see what they're movie stars mean to them,
there's a population there,
you know,
that is below the poverty line in a very high part of the population.
And that that type of cinema is so well catered to these massives.
You know,
it's the perfect form of escape is in the dancing,
the colors,
the,
you know,
big spectacle and uh,
I mean that cinema is changing,
but for me it's just,
it's an inspiration,
you know,
it provides hope and yeah.
You know,
in terms of technology,
I guess,
uh,
it's becoming simpler to be able to tell stories now.
You know,
people are telling shooting movies on their phones now you're capable of doing
that.
Uh,
you need less and less people and you know,
the equipment's getting smaller and more powerful.
So it's making it easier and more accessible to a wider range of people to be
able to go in and shoot a film.
You know,
we shot some of the scenes in Slumdog on a little canon camera.
I think it was like 45 frames per second and you blend them together and it
creates,
is slightly jumpy.
But that's what Donna used as the memory,
the flashbacks and it creates stuck a real visceral color and a kind of
dreamlike quality to stuff.
But,
uh,
you know,
it with last month as you make money makes you more adaptable and a good things
come from that.
So that's what happened in that situation.
But anyway.
Thanks.
Next question.
Hi,
I'm grace.
Um,
I recently just showing the Google marketing team,
um,
and I was just wondering like from your guys' perspective,
since you all played such a different kind of role and had different
perspectives and experiences interacting with the story,
um,
what particularly surprised you the most in terms of what you learned or
something that you didn't expect to happen or discover?
Um,
can you just share that insight with us?
Wow.
They don't ask easy questions around it and uh,
that's how,
what it was something I learned that I didn't ex at discovery that I didn't
expect.
I might take a,
I need to think about that for a minute.
No,
sorry,
go for it man.
You know that you guys
were all stumped.
Yeah,
you got us.
Actually,
I,
I didn't really know.
You know,
I did what I did and then all of a sudden all these things just uneven,
envisaged or this to come about.
And for me,
I'm just taking it a step at a time.
And,
uh,
even though everything is expedited so much from,
um,
you know,
finding my family to all of a sudden the news going global,
um,
to a book,
to a movie and then a stage show as well.
Um,
you know,
about a year ago I was still processing that I've done something so amazing,
which is to form a family and that's something just doesn't,
you know,
gets diffused the weight off your shoulders,
just like that.
And I think it's just being,
you know,
in time that will sort of hit me that,
um,
you know,
you've done something incredible and you know,
um,
you should be proud of it.
So,
uh,
and I am so,
but it's just taking time because there's so many other things.
Um,
but yeah,
to answer your question,
that's sort of a how I feel at the moment.
Yeah.
I mean,
as an actor kind of feel like I've grown so much,
you know,
it's hard with someone that looks like me to get,
um,
such a diverse,
meaty journey to go on roles.
So,
you know,
this has been a beautiful journey cause you know,
there's this,
this young man here who's resin through so much adversity and has been generous
and brave enough to share their story to the world.
And then there takes a talented team like Garth,
our director and Luke,
you know,
to bring it even further and closer and breathe life into it.
And then I,
you know,
I get to step on and put the icing on the cake.
But,
uh,
it's really been a journey of exploration.
What I have learned,
which it comes up at the end of the film is,
uh,
you know,
80,000 children,
go missing every year in India.
That I did not,
no,
I did not know this scale of,
uh,
of,
of this situation that we want to talk about,
you know,
and uh,
films like this can allow this conversation to happen,
you know,
and you know,
if it changes the life of one child,
then you know,
we've,
you know,
that it makes it all worthwhile,
but,
uh,
this is a recurring problem and,
you know,
hopefully we can bring light into this situation.
I do.
I remember discovery,
uh,
an amazingly funny moment.
So there's the scene in the middle of the film where little son,
he was walking along,
he finds a spoon in the ground and there's a funeral going on.
There's a little boy being carried along on an open a thing by a bunch of men
and they're all chanting.
And so the producers in India,
they were doing all the casting stuff for that day's shoot.
They were like,
we need 15 men and we need,
uh,
the dead 11 year old boy and the,
one of the casting companies comes back and they're like,
we're all good with the 15 men were having a bit of trouble with the 11 year old
boy.
And the producers are like,
what are you talking about?
And they're like,
well,
the police permissions,
it's really difficult to find a dead 11.
Wow.
That's something you,
next question please.
Hi Guys,
thank you for being here.
Thanks for sharing the story.
Um,
I have a six year old son.
It's struck a big chord for me.
Cried the whole time.
You'd be happy.
Um,
my Saru is for you,
the scene in the movie where you are taken in by a woman and it seems great.
It seems like she's warm and it's a safe place and then you started feeling like
it wasn't,
and then you left.
You escaped.
How as a five year old being by yourself like that,
did you navigate those situations and instinctually know not to stay with her?
That particular scene?
Um,
with Rama,
who's the guy that came in that tipped it off because I had a gut feeling,
um,
that,
you know,
as a child,
that's what happened.
You know,
it just didn't feel that the situation was right.
It was more wrong than anything else.
So,
um,
that's how really sort of,
came about that,
you know,
they're not really here to help me.
I'm the guy,
you know,
things would it be too close with,
uh,
it's,
you know,
whichever way is going to sort of go.
But you know,
I didn't want to find that out,
which was going to go.
So it made the valley in attempt to run off and you know,
maybe they were going to help me,
but,
um,
but my gut feeling is telling me,
no,
this is wrong and you need to get out.
And so I did.
Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
thanks for coming.
I first just wanted to acknowledge your point about the drowning scene.
I actually haven't seen the movie yet,
so I didn't know that was cut.
And I thought that was profound in the book because it just reminds me about how
life is a combination of your,
your personal tenacity.
Obviously your story is pretty much all about your personal is nasty,
but then those moments of sheer luck and guardian angels or whatever it may be,
that combined with,
um,
your intent to get to get you to where your eyes anyway,
it was interesting to hear you talk about that.
My question however,
is really about what compelled you to write a book.
And especially,
you know,
given it's an autobiographical,
I just kind of am always in awe of people who feel compelled to put their story
in writing for public consumption.
We'll,
um,
I actually got asked to write a book from a for publishing companies.
I'm not actually,
not that I actually went out there and I'm asking you to write a story about
this because it's so personal.
But,
um,
but the thing about it is that,
it just went sort of snowballed in India and everywhere in India when I first,
you know,
found my family and,
uh,
from India,
you know,
went to sort of Australia and then the whole world.
And,
um,
that's when,
you know,
sort of publishers,
um,
got hold of or knew about the story and got in contact.
And so I had a choice of,
um,
you know,
sorta telling my story,
which in fact has been out,
you know,
it's out a really didn't,
I did have a choice of like not telling it and sort of how keeping it private,
but I thought,
you know,
what I did is just so unique,
profound and amazing,
and if it could help someone else that's been,
like I said before,
my situation and that's,
well,
that's gold for me.
Um,
and so I grab the bull by the horns and,
um,
and I decided a year I'll write a book about it.
And,
um,
and you know,
the process started and your needs now graduation.
Thank you.
One more question.
Okay.
Hey,
hey.
Um,
I really enjoyed the movie.
I thought it did a really good job of showing complexity and I think,
um,
of the situation and at the end you feel grateful,
but you also feel this heaviness that,
that there's just,
it's a complex story and I think you all really pulled it off really well.
And my question is first,
so do,
there's this point in the,
um,
in the movie where you,
you know,
you go to the,
the,
um,
you eat Indian food and you're at in your at and t and you kind of,
it hits you and these memories come back.
And so my question is really,
it's very,
I find memories very interesting and kind of,
I was really curious in leaving the film,
did those memories haunt you or as you grew up or when did you carry them with
you?
Or did they suddenly come back to you and you couldn't resist them?
Um,
do question actually.
And um,
and the reason for those,
um,
I guess it's called,
uh,
juxtaposing where you're living down.
Then all of a sudden I get a flashback and that's what they were,
they were,
they were flashbacks.
And the way that flashbacks were triggered was the scene with the jelaby.
Um,
and the ones that are not in the movie would be a flashback,
would be triggered by,
um,
I would see,
you know,
a family,
um,
in Australia,
even though I've got my adoptive family,
the old see other families there and that have,
you know,
the to the nuclear family,
they had the,
you know,
two kids in the mother and father and all of a sudden just saying that,
um,
I'd be in a sort of straight of frame of mind of um,
you know,
sort of just,
sort of wondering about my,
you know,
my past life and that just by looking at that would trigger things.
And I would sort of remember,
you know,
border was life for myself.
Um,
as a char to be playing with my sister,
running around my mom's leg in know salary and,
you know,
playing sort of,
um,
hide and seek.
So,
um,
so that's,
you know,
that was one of the things that sort of stayed with me by these trigger points
and there was multiples of them.
Um,
and you know,
that that made it sort of,
um,
sustained.
And that's why I'd probably also,
you know,
didn't lose those memories as well as sort of my dreams as well during the night
too.
So,
um,
but you know,
there,
there was times where we sort of,
you know,
you did just didn't know what to do with it.
Sometimes you just fill in a heap and,
um,
and about it,
you know,
in your personal self.
Um,
and you know,
there was also things that,
songs that would trigger members as well,
multiples of them and,
and you'd always,
and sometimes there was times where you just have just a whole heap of just
memories,
go flick,
flick,
flick or within thought,
sort of 30 seconds.
Um,
almost like,
you know,
when you see Predator,
I don't want to go that far,
but we're,
here's that kind of,
yeah,
that's how it was,
but,
you know,
multiples of them.
So,
um,
and yeah,
it's just,
you know,
memories like that.
I'm sort of glad that it was like that because it stayed in my memory.
Um,
and,
and I suppose maybe there was a reason for that,
that stay there.
It was meant to do something,
you know,
later on,
but I just hadn't worked in.
W just hadn't worked out at that point of time.
Excellent.
Well,
thank you everyone.
Thank you guys for your wonderful,
honest answers.
I think it was a great session,
and if you haven't seen the film,
please do.
It's a beautiful film and,
uh,
yeah,
thanks everyone.
[inaudible].